bonjour merci est d'être avec nous sur
arte france alors vous l'avez peut-être
vu il ya presque personne à la
manifestation à barbès
c'est vrai que le temps s'y prête pas et
puis la manifestation telle qu'elle
était organisée initialement voilà
c'était dans le but d'aller au zénith à
la villette voilà comme le meeting est
dépassée sur villepin ça peut expliquer
la faiblesse de la participation est
donc peut-être plus de monde à
villepinte en tout cas on le sait pas et
quand la police parle de journée à
risque concrètement ça veut dire quoi
des risques de débordements bon puisque
il est là c'est aussi que sur la partie
extrême droite il ya des appels à venir
contre-manifester la manifestation à
l'appel notamment de la cgt donc voilà
peut y avoir des éléments de violence
ou quoi cette manifestation depuis
barbes était donc pour dénoncer un les
idées du polémiste il n'y a pas de
contre manifestation à chaque fois qu'un
candidat organise un meeting ça veut
dire quoi qu'eric zemmour n'est pas un
candidat comme les autres
effectivement
ce où toutes les idées contre lesquels
la cgt se bat ça ils tirent des propos
racistes y tient des propos contre
contre les femmes il est vraiment ils
portent tous plus haïssable en politique
alors stéphane troussel un président du
département de seine saint denis a voulu
enfin s'est opposé en tout cas au
meeting d'eric zemmour il s'en est
expliqué dans une tribune au journal du
dimanche est ce que vous le comprenez
oui tout à fait un moment donné on est
en démocratie
on a le droit de s'exprimer mais le
racisme n'est pas une opinion c'est un
délit alors l'actualité cette semaine
c'était bien évidemment
l'officialisation de la candidature
d'eric zemmour son clip de campagne est
ce que vous l'avez vu d'ailleurs ce clip
de campagne qui a fait beaucoup
polémique en me rappelle je pars en
couple ait été aperçue à tout qu'est ce
que vous en avez pensé
de la mise en scène enfin c'est
complètement après ça colle aux
personnages n'est malheureusement pas eu
de surprise
parfois il ya des hasards de calendriers
sur la même journée je
une grande dame
alors notre reporter vous en parlais
tout à l'heure et l'ambassade des états
unis en france en cas donné l'ordre à
ses employés d'éviter les zones de
manifestations est ce que vous en savez
plus
non non j'ai pas de jeu pas
d'information là-dessus mais je pense
que là c'est les mesures de
prévention
en tout cas selon vous il n'y aura pas
de débordements à cette manifestation
qui peut-être
sera à villepinte en tout cas pour
l'instant on le sait pas c'était le
dispositif de
d'accord merci en tout cas d'avoir été
avec nous et d'avoir répondu à nos
questions frédéric aguillon je rappelle
que vous êtes secrétaire général de la
cgt préfecture de police de paris merci
à vous